GOOD MORNING THE ASSEMBLY IS NOW
IN SESSION. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
O'DONNELL NOTICES THE ABSENCE OF
A QUORUM THE SERGEANT ARMS WILL
PREPARE THE CHAMBERS AND BRING
IN THE.
MEMBERS
THE CLERK WILL PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
ACOSTA AGUIAR CURRY ALLEN.
ARAMBULA. BAKER.
BERMAN.
BIGELOW.
BLOOM.
BONTA.
BROUGH.
BURKE
COLORADO. CALDERON CARILLO
SURVIVES HAS CHAU. CHAVEZ
CHEN. DAVID CHIU.
CHOI.
KANSEN CHU.
COOLEY.
COOPER.
CUNNINGHAM.
DALLEY.
DALY.
EIGHT. FLORA.
FONG.
FRAZIER FRIEDMAN. GALLAGHER
CRISTINA GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA.
GIPSON GLORIA GONZALEZ FLETCHER
GRAY.
GRAYSON.
HARPER.
HOLDEN
IRWIN
JONES SAWYER.
KALRA.
KILEY.
LACKEY LEVINE. LIMON.
LOW. MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS.
MAYES
CARTY.
MEDINA MELENDEZ
MULLIN PURSUIT JI. NAZARIAN
OBERNOLTE O'DONNELL.
PATTERSON
QUIRK
QUIRK SILVA.
REYES RODRIGUEZ
RUBIO.
SALAS SANTIAGO.
STEINORTH STONE.
THURMOND.
TEAM VOEPEL. WALDRON.
WEBER.
WOULD.
YOU SPEAKER
MEMBERS A QUORUM IS PRESENT. WE
ASK OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS IN
THE REAR CHAMBER TO PLEASE RISE
FOR THE PRAYER.
TODAY'S A VOCATION WILL BE
OFFERED BY OUR ASSEMBLY CHAPLAIN
REVEREND BOB OSHITA. REVEREND.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN A MOMENT OF
REFLECTION.
WE RECENTLY LEARNED THAT OUR
PREVIOUS BISHOP AND DEAR FRIEND.
SOCIAL COACHING OVERLY. IS
RETIRING FROM ACTIVE MINISTRY
FROM THE TEMPLE IN THE STATE OF
WASHINGTON.
AT THE AGE OF SEVENTY EIGHT
YOU'LL BE RETURNING TO KYOTO
JAPAN.
AS BISHOP IS MODEL WAS LET'S DO
SOMETHING NOW.
AND HE WOULD OFTEN ENCOURAGE
MINISTERS IN LEADERS. DON'T BE
AFRAID TO MAKE MISTAKES.
IT MEANS YOU'RE TRYING TO DO
SOMETHING.
I ALWAYS FELT THAT HIS
LEADERSHIP WAS ONE TO EMULATE.
UNCONCERNED WITH PERSONAL
ACCOLADES.
HE WAS MAGNETICALLY POPULAR WITH
YOUNG PEOPLE.
FOR HE ENGAGE THEM WITH COMPLETE
HONESTY.
YOU WAS EQUALLY UNCONCERNED WITH
HIS POPULARITY AMONG THE
MINISTERS THAT HE WAS
RESPONSIBLE FOR.
AGAIN HE ALSO ENGAGE THEM WITH
COMPLETE HONESTY.
AS IN ANY FIELD THERE WOULD BE
THOSE UNSUITED FOR THE ROLE HE
HAD HOPED TO FULFILL.
HE WOULD ENGAGE THESE MINISTERS
TO. WITH COMPLETE HONESTY AND
COMPASSION.
HE WOULD TELL THEM.
MY LETTING YOU GO IS AN ACT OF
KINDNESS.
YOU HAVE ONLY ONE LIFE TO LIVE.
PLEASE DO NOT WASTE YOUR ONLY
LIFE
TRYING TO DO SOMETHING YOU WILL
NEVER DO VERY WELL. NOR WILL IT
MAKE YOU HAPPY.
SO TO AGREE AS THE WITH THEM OF
HUMANITY SPIRITUAL VISIONARIES
AND POETS.
WHOSE WORDS BEING UNIVERSALLY
TRUE.
AS THE PERSIAN SPIRITUAL POET
RUMI HAS SAID.
WHEN WE STOP ADMIRING OURSELVES
THEN ALL WE DO WILL BECOME
ADMIRABLE.
SO IT HAS BEEN WITH PHOTO AGREE.
I WILL MISS THE UNASSUMING
HONESTY AND KINDNESS OF MY DEAR
FRIEND.
NOW MORE AND. WITH KINDNESS
INGRATITUDE BEYOND WORDS.
THANK YOU REVEREND. INVITE YOU
TO REMAIN STANDING FOR TODAY'S
FLAG SALUTE WILL TO BE BE LED BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER COOPER.
PLEASE JOIN ME DURING OUR FLAG I
PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE.
YOU MAY BE SEATED.
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL. ASSEMBLY CHAMBER
SACRAMENTO WEDNESDAY FEBRUARY
FOURTEENTH TWENTY MISTER
CALDERON MOVES AND MISS WALDRON
SECONDS AT THE READING OF THE
PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL BE
DISPENSED WITH.
PRESENTATIONS OF PETITIONS THERE
ARE NONE. INTRODUCTION AND
REFERENCE OF BILLS WILL BE
DEFERRED REPORTS OF COMMITTEES
WILL BE DEEMED READ AND
AMENDMENTS DEEMED ADOPTED
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR THERE
ARE NONE. MESSAGES FROM THE
SENATE THERE ARE NONE.
ALL ABSENCES WILL BE DEEMED READ
AND PRINTED IN THE JOURNAL.
MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR MOTIONS.
YOU MADAM MADAM SPEAKER I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE ONE
EIGHTEEN A TO ALLOW THE SPEAKER
TO HAVE GUESTS AND PHOTOGRAPHERS
ON THE FLOOR TODAY. WITHOUT
OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE THE
ORDER THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I
ALSO REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT
TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE FORTY
FIVE POINT FIVE AND ALLOW SOME.
COOPER AND BAKER TO SPEAK.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER.
MEMBERS WE HAVE GUESTS WITH US
IN THE ASSEMBLY TODAY.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CERVANTES YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GUESTS
INTRODUCTIONS MEMBERS PLEASE
GIVE YOUR ATTENTION TOASSEMBLY
MEMBER CERVANTES.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER SITTING
UP IN THE GALLERY WITH S. TODAY
I WOULD LIKE TO TAKE THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO RECOGNIZE THE
HONORABLE LAURA RIGHT IN. SHE'S
OUR COUNCIL MEMBER IN THE CITY
OF GROUP OF VALLEY LAURA HAS
BEEN A RESIDENT OF RIVER VALLEY
SINCE NINETEEN NINETY AND WAS
INVOLVED IN THE CITY'S
INCORPORATION. EFFORTS IN TWO
THOUSAND SIX
WHEN THEY ARE RIVER VALLEY WAS
INCORPORATED IN TWENTY ELEVEN
SHE SERVED AS THE CITY'S FIRST
MAYOR. THANK YOU LORD FOR ALL
YOUR DEDICATION TO OUR CITY AND
I LOOK FORWARD TO OUR CONTINUED
PARTNERSHIP. PLEASE IF WE CAN
WELCOME ARE HONORABLE COUNCIL
MEMBER TO THE ASSEMBLY CHAMBER.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER MEDINA
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND.
MEMBERS IT IS MY DISTINCT
PLEASURE TO INTRODUCE THIS
MORNING.
A GOOD FRIEND.
PATRICIA LOT DAWSON.
PATRICIA IS PRESIDENT OF THE
RIVERSIDE UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT BOARD OF TRUSTEES.
PRESIDENTOF THE RIVERSIDE LAND
CONSERVANCY AND A NATIVE OF
RIVERSIDE.
I I THANK PATRICIA FOR ALL THE
GOOD WORK THAT SHE'S DONE.
AND PLEASE LET'S WELCOME WARMLY
PATRICIA LOCKED US.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER REYES YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GUESTS
INTRODUCTIONS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MADAM SPEAKER
AND MEMBERS.
IS A GREAT HONOR TO INTRODUCE TO
YOU SOME OF THE BRIGHTEST
YOUNG PEOPLE FROM THE SAN
BERNARDINO COUNTY FORTY SEVENTH
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT. THESE ARE MY
INAUGURAL CLASS
OF THE YOUNG LEGISLATORS FOR A
D. FORTY SEVEN.
THESE ARE STUDENTS WHO REPRESENT
THE CITY'S OF SANDRA DINO RIALTO
FONTANA COLDS AND MUST A GRAND
TERRACE.
AND BLOOMINGTON.
THEY A BAND WITH US FOR NINE
MONTHS AND IT TODAY IS THEIR
TRIP TO SACRAMENTO. THANK YOU
FOR WELCOMING THEM PLEASE JOIN
ME IN WELCOMING THEM.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK IS SPEAKER MEMBERS WE HAVE
STUDENTS FROM MY DISTRICT.
ABOVE ME IN THE GALLERY.
THESE ARE TENTH AND ELEVENTH
GRADE STUDENTS WHO ARE PART OF
THE AVID AND POINTED PROJECT
PROGRAM IF HE WERE IN HIGH
SCHOOL.
THEY ARE PARTICIPATING IN THE
TWENTY EIGHTEEN NOR CAL COLLEGE
TOUR WHERE THEY WILL VISIT SEVEN
UNIVERSITIES AND COLLEGES.
IN THE SPAN OF FOUR DAYS THEY'RE
MAKING A QUICK STOP AT THE
CAPITOL BEFORE HEADING OVER TO
SACRAMENTO STATE.
ALL OF OUR STUDENTS ARE FIRST
GENERATION COLLEGE BOUND
STUDENTS PLEASE GIVE THEM A WARM
ASSEMBLY WELCOME
.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING TO
BUSINESS ON THE DAILY ITEMS ONE
THROUGH FOUR WILL BE
PASS AND RETAIN.
ITEM FIVE IS HERE WHEN SIXTY
FOUR MADAM CLERK PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
ONE SIXTY FOUR BY SOME THE
MEMBER CUNNINGHAM AND OTHERS
RELATIVE TO CAREER TECHNICAL
EDUCATION MONTH.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CUNNINGHAM YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER.
MEMBERS PLEASE JOIN ME.
IN VOTING FOR THIS RESOLUTION
WAS DESIGNATES FEBRUARY AS
CAREER TECHNICAL EDUCATION
MONTH.
I AM PROUD OF THE BIPARTISAN
WORK THIS BODIES.
DONE ALREADY AND CONTINUES TO DO
TO SUPPORT CAREER TECHNICAL
EDUCATION.
IT'S NO SECRET WE HAVE A SKILLS
GAP IN OUR COUNTRY AND OUR
STATE.
WE HAVE RETIRING BABY BOOMERS
OUT OF THE SKILLED TRADES.
AND THERE'S TREMENDOUS
OPPORTUNITY FOR OUR KIDS AND THE
TIME IS RIGHT TO TAKE ADVANTAGE
OF THAT OPPORTUNITY. BY
SUPPORTING CT.
CONSIDER THAT A PERSON WITH THE
PLUMBING CERTIFICATES STARTS
WITH AN AVERAGE SALARY SIXTY
EIGHT THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR.
A WELL THERE MAKES THE IN AN
AVERAGE SALARY OF NINETY
THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR THERE'S
TREMENDOUS OPPORTUNITY IN THESE
FIELDS BUT IS NOT JUST THE
SKILLED TRADES. IT'S EARLY
CHILDHOOD ED IT'S.
GRAPHIC DESIGN ITS IT AT CYBER
ITS ACT TECHNOLOGY.
CT SUPPORTS GIVING OPPORTUNITY
IN ALL THESE FIELDS TO OUR KIDS
IT PREPARES THEM FOR LIFE IT
PREPARES THEM FOR COLLEGE
PREPARES THEM FOR A CAREER.
AND IT'S PERHAPS THE MOST
IMPORTANT INVESTMENT WE CAN MAKE
IN OUR COLLECTIVE FUTURE.
THANK YOU AND PLEASE JOIN ME IN
VOTING FOR THIS RESOLUTION.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
O'DONNELL YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I AM
PROUD TO BE A JOINT AUTHOR OF AC
OR ACR ONE SIXTY FOUR. MAKING
CERTAIN THAT OUR K. TWELVE
SCHOOLS HAVE FUNDING NECESSARY
TO DELIVER HIGH QUALITY C. T.
PROGRAMS IS A PRIORITY FOR ME.
AND I HOPE MANY OF YOU THIS
YEAR.
AS A TEACHER I KNOW FIRST HAND
THAT CT PROGRAMS REDUCE DROPOUT
RATES AND ENGAGE STUDENTS.
STUDENTS NEED TO MULTIPLE PAST
SUCCESS.
NOT EVERY JOB REQUIRES A FOR
YOUR UNIT UNIVERSITY DEGREE AND
WE KNOW NOT EVERY STUDENT IS
GOING TO GET. A FOUR YEAR
UNIVERSITY DEGREE.
CURRENTLY THERE IS A SHORTAGE OF
WELDERS CODERS AND OTHER JOBS
THAT REQUIRE TECHNICAL APTITUDE.
THIS EFFORT IS ABOUT CALIFORNIA
ENSURING STUDENT SUCCESS BUT
ALSO ECONOMIC SUCCESS
THANK YOU MINISTRY.
THANK YOU SOME MEMBER BURKE YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS AS CHAIR OF THE SELECT
COMMITTEE ON CAREER TECHNICAL
EDUCATION I RISE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF ACR ONE SIXTY FOUR.
I'VE HELPED SELECT COMMITTEES
ACROSS THE STATE OVER THE PAST
THREE YEARS ON THIS TOPIC AND
IT'S BEEN AMAZING TO SEE THAT
SEE AND HEAR THE OUTPOURING OF
COMMUNITY SUPPORT FOR C. TEAM.
THIS YEAR IS ANOTHER CRITICAL
BUDGET YOUR FIRST CD BECAUSE IN
MANY CASES WITHOUT THE STEADY
STREAM OF FUNDING THESE PROGRAMS
SIMPLY WOULD JUST WON'T EXIST.
THIS FUNDING FOR CTA PROGRAMS
ONLY HELP STUDENTS DREAM A
POSSIBILITIES FOR THEIR FUTURE
AND ACHIEVE SUCCESS BUT IT ALSO
CREATES LOCAL BONDS BETWEEN
BUSINESS LABOR AND GOVERNMENT
THAT CAN LAST GENERATIONS.
AT THE STATE I BELIEVE WE SHOULD
BE DOING MORE TO REWARD BUSINESS
THAT PARTNER WITH LOCAL SCHOOLS
THIS NOT ONLY HELPS BUILD A
STRONG COMMUNITY BUT IT ALSO CAN
HELP DISTRICTS DEVELOP
CURRICULUM AND PROVIDE STUDENTS
WITH PRE APPRENTICESHIP OR WORK
STUDY OPPORTUNITIES. TO HAVE
EXPERIENCE IN WORKFORCE.
IT'S BEEN REPORTED THAT THERE
ARE CURRENTLY ONE MILLION MIDDLE
CLASS JOBS REQUIRE SOLELY A
CERTIFICATE THAT CONTINUE. TO
REMAIN UNFILLED BECAUSE WE HAVE
NOT PROVIDED A PATHWAY FOR
CALIFORNIANS GET THE EDUCATION
THAT THEY NEED TO FILL THOSE
JOBS.
THAT MONEY LAW IS LOST TO THE
ECONOMY AND PRODUCTION IN TAX
REVENUE AND MONEY LOST IN SOCIAL
SERVICES BUT WORSE THAT IS SELF
RESPECT THAT WE TAKE AWAY FROM
SMART PEOPLE WHO JUST NEED AN
OPPORTUNITY. A CHANCE TO SHOW
THAT THEY ARE CAPABLE AND THAT
TO ME IS THE BIGGEST DISSERVICE
OF OFF.
I AM PROUD TO HAVE WORKED WITH
THE TRULY BIPARTISAN GROUP ON
THIS ISSUE AND I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE ON ACR ONE
SIXTY.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RODRIGUEZ YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS
ALSO RISE IN SUPPORT OF ACR ONE
SIXTY FOUR.
THE CAREER TECHNICAL EDUCATION.
IS AND HOW IT'S BEEN THE
BACKBONE OF OUR WORKFORCE
HOPPING STUDENTS TRANSITION INTO
WORKFORCE IN MANY.
INDUSTRIES
COMPUTER SCIENCE SPORTS
MANAGEMENT WELDING AND EMERGENCY
MEDICAL RESPONSE ARE JUST SOME
OF THE MANY EXAMPLES OF CT
PROGRAMS IN MY DISTRICTS.
AS AN EMERGENCY MEDICAL
TECHNICIAN FOR OVER THIRTY YEARS
I HAVE PERSONALLY EXPERIENCED
THE BENEFITS OF AXIS
TO SEE T. COURSES AND HAVE
UTILIZED THAT EDUCATION TO GIVE
BACK AND HOW MY COMMUNITY
THROUGHOUT MY CAREER.
I KNOW THEM POINTS OF EDUCATE
OUR STUDENTS ON ALL THE OPTIONS
AVAILABLE TO THEM AFTER HIGH
SCHOOL AND SUPPORT THEIR EFFORTS
TO RAISE AWARENESS ENROLLMENT I
ALSO STRICTLY OUT FOR A VOTE. ON
ACR ONE SIXTY FOUR THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
THURMAN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
Q. MEN SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES I
RISE IN SUPPORT OF ACR ONE SIXTY
FOUR LIKE TO THANK MY COLLEAGUE
FROM SAN LUIS OBISPO. FOR HIS
LEADERSHIP IN BRINGING IT
FORWARD. AYE AYE.
I RISE IN SUPPORT OF THE
CLEARING FEBRUARY AS CAREER
TECHNICAL EDUCATION MONTH.
AS YOU'VE HEARD THERE'S NO
DOUBT THAT WE NEED TO BE MAKING
CAREER TECHNICAL EDUCATION. A
PRIORITY IN OUR STATE.
THESE OPPORTUNITIES GIVE
STUDENTS ANOTHER CHANCE IN THEIR
EDUCATIONAL PATH THAT HELPS THEM
TO STAY ENGAGE IN ON A PATH TO
SUCCESS.
BUT WE MUST DO MORE.
IN CALIFORNIA. WE WILL HAVE A
SHORTAGE OF ONE POINT FIVE
MILLION TECHNICAL WORKERS BY
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE.
THAT'S WHY I'M PROUD OF THIS
EFFORT TODAY BUT ALSO PROUD TO
JOIN MANY OF THOSE THAT YOU'VE
HEARD FROM. IN A BILL THIS YEAR
THAT WILL PROVIDE DOLLARS TO
SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO ENSURE THE
DELIVERY OF HIGH QUALITY CAREER
TECHNICAL EDUCATION PROGRAMS.
WHAT WE NEED TO PROVIDE THESE
RESOURCES TO OUR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS
I WAS VERY PROUD THIS PAST YEAR
TO ATTEND? A CT  GRADUATION
IN THE SEED DOZENS OF CAREER
OPPORTUNITIES OF THAT OUR
STUDENTS HAD THE CHANCE TO HAVE
EXPOSURE TO. UMD IN PARTICULAR
AT BERKELEY UNIFIED DO WE HAVE
THE CARPENTERS PARTICIPATE IN
THE PROGRAM AND AT THE ALAMEDA
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION. WE
LITERALLY HAD A GRADUATION OF
TWO DOZEN.
PARTICIPANTS IN DIFFERENT
FIELDS WE KNOW THAT WITHOUT
ADDITIONAL FUNDING THESE
PROGRAMS WILL NOT BE SUCCESSFUL
AYE URGENT AYE VOTE. NOT JUST
FOR THE RESOLUTION NON A
COMMITMENT TO WORK ON REMOVING
BARRIERS THAT STAND BETWEEN GOOD
PAYING AN IN DEMAND JOBS AND
OPPORTUNITIES FOR OUR YOUTH AND
STUDENTS I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRAZIER
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I STAND
IN AND RISE IN A SUPPORTIVE ACR
ONE SIXTY FOUR. AND JUST IMPLORE
MY COLLEAGUES TO INCLUDE. THIS
NOT ONLY IN FEBRUARY BUT EVERY
MONTH OF THE YEAR I'M A BY
PRODUCT OF A CT I DIDN'T HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO GO TO
COLLEGE.
I HAD VOCATIONAL ED IN HIGH
SCHOOL WHICH LED ME TO A PATH.
TO APPRENTICESHIP TRAINING IN IN
CARPENTRY THEN BECAME A JOURNAL
CARP UNDER A MASTER CARPENTER
THEN A CONTRACTOR.
IT LED ME ON A SUCCESSFUL PATH.
I WANT TO THANK. THE PEOPLE THAT
WERE.
SIR IN SUPPORT OF IT AT THAT
TIME BECAUSE WHO KNOWS WHAT
WOULD HAVE HAPPENED HAD I NOT
HAD THAT OPPORTUNITY. BUT I WILL
ALSO TELL YOU THAT IN NINETEEN
EIGHTY ONE DURING A HIGH HOUSING
CRISIS I LOST MY JOB WAS ABLE TO
GO TO REGIONAL OCCUPATIONAL
PROGRAMS. AND LEARN ANOTHER
CRAFT ALSO THAT I WAS ABLE TO
GET A JOB IN THE REFINERIES.
THESE ARE PROGRAMS THAT HELP
PEOPLE EVERY DAY AND I WOULD.
LOVE TO SEE US.
OF OUR BUDGET CHAIRS ARE SUB
BUDGET CHAIRS TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE FIGHT FOR THIS ON ONGOING
BASIS AND A COMMITMENT TO
TO SUPPORT THE CHILDREN. LIKE WE
TOLD WE WOULD PULL THESE
CHILDREN THAT WE WOULD.
APPEARS AND REMAINING STRONG ON
THEIR BEHALF.
I URGE THE AYE VOTE ON ACR ONE
SIXTY FOUR.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER AGUIAR
CURRY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AC ONE
SIXTY FOUR. I'M I HAVE
WITNESSED.
IN THE PAST COUPLE WEEKS WITH
THE OF FUTURE FARMERS OF AMERICA
YOU MAY HAVE SEEN MANY OF THESE
YOUNG MEN AND WOMEN IN OUR
OFFICES THIS PAST WEEK. AND THEY
HAVE BEEN ABLE TO TAKE ADVANTAGE
OF THE THE PROGRAMS WITH CT
. WE'VE SEEN WELDERS WE'VE
SEEN ELECT PEOPLE TO LEARN TO BE
ELECTRICIANS A WE LOOKED AT MANY
YOUNG PEOPLE THAT LOW ABOUT FARM
MECHANICS.
I WITNESSED A HUNDRED AND
TWELVE SCHOOLS COME UP TO MY
DISTRICT UP IN SMALL TOWN OF OUR
BUCKLE CALIFORNIA AND COMPETE IN
MECHANICS IN WELDING. I WANT TO
TELL YOU THE FROM I'M A STAMP
POINT IS I THINK WE SHOULD
ALWAYS SUPPORT THE CT
THANK YOU SO MUCH AND I SUPPORT
A SEAT ONE SIX.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER GIPSON
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I RISE TODAY
IN SUPPORT OF ACR ONE SIXTY FOUR
THIS RESOLUTION IS A VERY
IMPORTANT.
TO ME BECAUSE I REPRESENT ONE
OF THE MOST POPPERS ASSEMBLY
DISTRICTS IN THE STATE AND I AM
COMMITTED.
I'M CONVINCED THAT HIGH QUALITY
CAREER TECHNICAL EDUCATION WOULD
DRAMATICALLY IMPROVE THE LIVES
OF INDIVIDUALS IN MY COMMUNITY I
WANNA THANK THE AUTHOR FOR THIS
BECAUSE I REALIZE. THAT GIVE A
MAN A WOMAN A JOB WE STOP
BULLETS WE STOPPED DRIVE BY
SHOOTINGS AND THINGS OF THAT
NATURE AND SO THIS IS A STEP IN
THE RIGHT DIRECTION WE SHOULD
FULLY FUND.
CAREER TECHNICAL EDUCATION OF
OF THOSE WHO WOULD NOT HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY OR HAVE NO DESIRE TO
GO TO COMMUNITY COLLEGE OR
UNIVERSITY SO. OUT PLEASE JOIN
ME MEMBERS SUPPORTING ACR ONE
SIXTY FOUR.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CARILLO YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS
I RISE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
THIS RESOLUTION AND THE BENEFITS
OF CAREER TECHNICAL EDUCATION
RCT.
IN THE FIFTY FIRST ASSEMBLY
DISTRICT THIRTY PERCENT OF
RESIDENTS
THAT ARE LIVING IN BUT THEN MY
DISTRICT ARE LIVING AND
STRUGGLING BELOW THE NATIONAL
POVERTY LINE THIRTY PERCENT OF
THEM.
JOB CREATION AND WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT ARE INSTRUMENTAL IN
ADDRESSING THIS CRISIS THE
DIGNITY OF WORK AND CAREER
OPPORTUNITY IS A RIGHT OF ALL
PEOPLE.
MEMBERS IN MY OWN FAMILY HAVE
BENEFITTED FROM CAREER TECHNICAL
AND EDUCATION I CAN ATTEST TO
YOU WHAT IT DOES TO BRING PEOPLE
OUT OF POVERTY. WE MUST PROVIDE
AVENUES FOR ALL PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA TO LIFT THEMSELVES
OUT OF POVERTY THROUGH ACCESS TO
SKILL BASE EDUCATION. QUALITY
AND GOOD PAYING JOBS JOBS WITH
DIGNITY.
C. T. E. CAN OFFER A PATHWAY TO
A BETTER LIFE BY CREATING A
SKILLED WORKFORCE THAT CAN MEET
THE NEEDS OF OUR INDUSTRIES IN
OUR DIVERSE COMMUNITIES AND
ECONOMIES.
THE DEMAND FOR A SKILLED
WORKFORCE CONTINUES TO GROW AND
WE SHOULD RISE TO MEET AND
ENSURE THE ECONOMIC SECURITY OF
RESIDENTS OF OUR GREAT STATE.
I WOULD LIKE TO THANK MY
COLLEAGUE FROM SAN LUIS OBISPO
FOR BRINGING THIS RESOLUTION
FORWARD. AND I URGE YOUR SUPPORT
ON ACR ONE SIXTY FOUR THANK YOU.
SOME NUMBER DOLLY ARE RECOGNIZED
THEY EVEN SPEAKER MEMBERS I TO
VOTE ALSO RISE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS I. THINK A GOOD MEMBER FROM
A SLOW FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD
AS A BUSINESS OWNER AND.
SOMEBODY WHO HAS TWO. YOUNG MEN
IN THE FFA PROGRAM UP NORTH ONE
OF THEM A SUPERIOR REGION
OFFICER.
THESE ARE THE KIND OF SKILLED
JOBS THEY LEARN THE SKILLS THAT
WE USE ON OUR FARMS. THESE ARE
HIGH PAYING JOBS AT LEAST IT
ALSO TEACH THEM LIFE SKILLS SO.
STRONG SUPPORTER AND I I THINK
YOU FOR BRING THIS MEASURE FOR
AND URGE AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY LACKEY YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED.
YES BAKER MEMBERS I JUST WANT TO
MAKE CLARIFYING. A STATEMENT
HERE THE CT HAS NOTHING TO DO
WITH CONCUSSIONS.
AND.
I WANT.
EVERYBODY TO KNOW THAT I'M VERY
HAVE BEEN VERY SADDENED
THROUGHOUT MY LIFE TO WATCH THE
DE EMPHASIS.
A VOCATIONAL TRAINING AND THAT
NOW WE'RE ACTUALLY MOVING BACK
AND TO THE ARENA THAT RECOGNIZES
OTHER TALENTS OTHER TO JUST
TECHNICAL TALENTS. AND I I WOULD
SUGGEST THAT WE JUST.
CHANGE THIS.
NOMENCLATURE TO CAREER.
EDUCATION AND TAKE THE TEETH OUT
SO THERE'S NOT AYE. AFFILIATION
WITH THIS OTHER VERY TRAGIC
CIRCUMSTANCE.
BUT.
VERY PROUD TO SUPPORT ACR ONE
SIXTY FOUR AND ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT.
THINK YOU SING NO FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE MISTER
CUNNINGHAM WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE.
MADAM SPEAKER I WOULD JUST ASK
THE FIRST RULE BE OPEN FOR CO
AUTHORS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE THIS ROSE. OFFERS.
MEMBERS THIS ROLE IS FOR CO
AUTHORS.
MEMBERS THIS ROLE IS FOR COAL
MADAM CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLE. THEIR SIXTY ONE CO
AUTHORS.
WITHOUT OBJECTION WILL TAKE A
VOICE VOTE ON THIS ITEM ALL
THOSE IN FAVOR SIGNIFY BY SAYING
AYE.
ALL OPPOSED.
THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
ITEM SIX RATE PASS AND RETAIN.
THE CLERK WILL PLEASE READ ITEM
NINE SIA ARE FIFTY SEVEN.
SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
FIFTY SEVEN BY SENATOR CANNELLA
AND OTHERS RELATIVE TO MEMORIAL
HIGHWAYS.
THANK YOU SO MEMBER COPIER YOU
RECOGNIZE THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I RISE TODAY
TO PRESENT S. C. OUR FIFTY SEVEN
ON BEHALF OF SENATOR CANNELLA
AND THE COUNTY OF MONTEREY.
TO HONOR THE LIVES OF THESE FIVE
ARMY VETERANS WHO DIED IN
AFGHANISTAN.
UNITED STATES ARMY CHIEF WARRANT
OFFICER TO EDWARD VOLLEY FROM
SALINAS. UNITED STATES ARMY
RANGERS SPECIALISTS NIKAD GO
CEDRAS JUNIOR FROM SALINAS.
UNITED STATES ARMY SPECIALIST
BILL MAHER GALARZA HERNANDEZ
ALSO FROM SALINAS.
UNITED STATES ARMY SERGEANT
HUBBY OUR SCIENTISTS FROM
GREENFIELD. AND UNITED STATES
ARMY PRIVATE FIRST CLASS CORN
DRIVE THOUGH DE HAVE YET FROM
ARENA. THEIR NAMES WILL BE
MEMORIALIZED WITH HIGHWAY
DESIGNATIONS THROUGHOUT MONTEREY
COUNTY. WE THANK THEM FOR THEIR
SERVICE AND SACRIFICES FOR THIS
NATION AND I ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WOULD YOU LIKE THE FIRST RULE TO
BE OPEN FOR COFFERS YES I WILL
ADMIT. OKAY MADAM CLERK PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLE.
THIS ROSE FOR COOPERS.
MEMBERS THIS.
ROLL CALL IS FOR COAL AUTHORS ON
SCR FIFTY SEVEN.
MEMBERS THIS ROLE IS FOR CO
AUTHORS.
BOTTOM QUIRK PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLE THERE ARE SIXTY ONE CALL
AUTHORS ABOUT OBJECTION WE WILL
TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THIS ITEM
ALL THOSE IN FAVOR SIGNIFY BY
SAYING AYE.
I.
ALL OPPOSED.
THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
WE ARE MOVING NOW TO
ANNOUNCEMENTS MEMBERS. THIS IS A
REMINDER THAT YOU MUST FILE YOUR
ANNUAL STATEMENT OF ECONOMIC
INTEREST FORM BY THURSDAY MARCH
FIRST.
NOTE THAT FORM SEVEN HUNDRED
MUST BE SUBMITTED TO THE CHIEF
CLERK ROOM THIRTY ONE NINETY SIX
BY FIVE PM. THIS DEADLINE IS FOR
MEMBERS DESIGNATED STAFF MUST
FILE BY APRIL THIRD TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN. THE SESSION SCHEDULE
IS AS FOLLOWS FEBRUARY TWENTY
THIRD NO FLOOR SESSION NO CHECK
IN SESSION MONDAY FEBRUARY
TWENTY SIXTH FLOOR SESSION AT
ONE PM.
IN THE ABSENCE OF A JOB
OBJECTION THE QUORUM CALLS
LIFTED AND WE WILL NOW MOVE TO
PREVIOUSLY. ANNOUNCED
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY.
OKAY WE ARE.
I AM SORRY WE ARE NOT LOOKING A
QUORUM I BEG YOUR PARDON MEMBERS
IF YOU CAN REMAIN IN YOUR SEATS.
MEMBERS WE HAVE SPECIAL GOOD
SPECIAL GUESTS WILL BE JOINING
US SO IF YOU CAN PLEASE TAKE
YOUR SEATS
.
MEMBERS PLEASE RETURN TO YOUR
SEATS WE HAVE VERY SPECIAL
GUESTS JOINING US IN CHAMBERS
TODAY
MEMBERS PLEASE GIVE YOUR
ATTENTION TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
KALRA WHO IS RECOGNIZED FOR
MISTER MULLINS DUST.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS
I'M HONORED TO HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ENTER DO SEVERAL
DISTINGUISHED GUESTS FROM
CANADA.
ONE OF OUR COUNTRY'S MOST
IMPORTANT GLOBAL PARTNERS
AND IT'S A SPECIFIC PUT
PRIVILEGE FOR ME AS THE ONLY
CURRENT. MEMBER OF THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE THOSE
BORN IN CANADA.
JOINING US ON THE FLOOR TODAY IS
THE HONORABLE LAWRENCE MACAULAY.
CANADA'S MINISTER OF AGRICULTURE
AGRICULTURE AND AGRO FOOD.
ACCOMPANYING HIM ARE TWO CONSUL
GENERALS REPRESENTING CANADA IN
SAN FRANCISCO AND LOS ANGELES.
RANA SUKAR AND JAMES A GOOD
NEWS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH OF VISITING
US%
HERE IN SACRAMENTO IS CERTAINLY
ARE PRIVILEGED TO HOST YOU.
ON BEHALF OF THE SPEAKER MY
COLLEAGUES IN THIS CHAMBER. WE
WANT TO WELCOME YOU TO THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSEMBLY.
AS YOU ALL ARE WELL AWARE GREAT
UNCERTAINTIES CHALLENGE OUR
WORLD TODAY.
HERE AT HOME AND ABROAD WE ARE
HEARING VOICES QUESTION.
WHETHER COMMUNITIES AND NATIONS
SHOULD CONTINUE TO ENHANCE TIES
BY DRAWS CLOSER.
WE WONDER WHETHER THE PRESSURES
PROJECT BORN IN THE POST WAR ERA
LIBERAL ORDER ADVANCING COMMON
UNDERSTANDING HUMAN RIGHTS AND
RULES CAN STILL OFFER ANSWERS.
TO A TO TWENTY FIRST CENTURY
CHALLENGES.
I THINK IT CAN BUT. TO DO SO WE
WILL NEED PEOPLE WHO ARE CAPABLE
OF BUILDING RELATIONSHIPS AND
BRIDGES ACROSS REGIONS. AND
CONTINENTS.
TO HELP OUR CITIZENS SEE THAT
THEY TOO CAN BENEFIT FROM AND
CONTRIBUTE TO A CONNECTED WORLD.
WE NEED IN OTHER WORDS GOOD
LEADERS AND DIPLOMATS LIKE WE
HAVE WITH US HERE TODAY.
AND THESE ARE SOME OF THE
FINEST MEMBERS AND EXAMPLES OF
THAT PARTICULARLY AS IT
PERTAINS.
TO THE CANADIAN. CALIFORNIA AS
WELL AS CANADIAN AND AMERICAN
RELATIONSHIP. I AM.
I WOULD THANK YOU ALL FOR THE
GREAT
WORK THAT YOU'RE DOING TO BUILD
RELATIONSHIPS
AND BRIDGES WHICH IN CALIFORNIA
AND CANADA WE ARE SO HONORED. TO
HAVE YOU AS OUR FRIENDS AND
PARTNERS SO THANK YOU
MEMBERS OBJECTION THE FORM
BECAUSE
LIFTED AND WE WILL MOVE IT NOW
MOVES TO PREVIOUSLY ANNOUNCED
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING TO
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BAKER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBER MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS.
I RISE TODAY TO ASK WE ADJOURN
IN THE MEMORY OF MY TESTS IN TOW
RESIDENT OF DANVILLE WHO PASSED
AWAY ON FEBRUARY FOURTEENTH THIS
YEAR. MIKE WAS BORN ON JANUARY
TWENTIETH IN NINETEEN FIFTY
THREE IN SAN JOSE WHICH IS FIFTY
FIVE YEARS OLD.
HE GREW UP IN FREMONT AND LATER
GRADUATED FROM WASHINGTON HIGH
SCHOOL IN NINETEEN SEVENTY ONE
WHERE HE WAS KNOWN AS AN
OUTSTANDING STUDENT AN
INCREDIBLY TALENTED AND
PASSIONATE ATHLETE. WHO LETTERED
IN FOOTBALL BASEBALL AND SOCCER?
HE WAS NAMED THE NINETEEN
SEVENTY SEVENTY ONE ATHLETE OF
THE YEAR BY THE MISSION VALLEY
ATHLETIC LEAGUE AND RECOGNIZE AS
ONE OF THE FOUNDING MEMBERS OF
THE HIGH SCHOOL'S ALUMNI
FOUNDATION.
MIKE LATER WENT ON TO ATTEND CAL
STATE HAYWARD WHERE HE PLAYED
QUARTERBACK AND WAS INDUCTED
INTO THE SCHOOL'S HALL OF FAME
IN NINETEEN EIGHTY EIGHT.
ASIDE FROM HIS ATHLETIC
ACHIEVEMENTS MIKE WAS ALSO VERY
WELL KNOWN AND VERY RESPECTED
ACCOMPLISHED BUSINESSMAN. HE
JOINED THE BAY EAST ASSOCIATION
OF REALTORS IN NINETEEN EIGHTY
ONE AND WAS RECOGNIZED AS THE
BAY EAST REALTOR OF THE YEAR IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY EIGHT.
IN NINETEEN NINETY HE WAS
ELECTED PRESIDENT TO THE BASED
ASSOCIATION OF REALTORS. AND HE
RECEIVED THE OUTSTANDING
LEADERSHIP AWARD THREE TIMES IN
NINETEEN NINETY THREE NINETY
EIGHT AND TWENTY FIFTEEN. HE
ALSO READ RECEIVE THE JOHN
DIETRICH LETTER LEADERSHIP AWARD
IN TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN THIS IS
AN AWARD NAMED AFTER THE
ASSOCIATION'S FIRST PRESIDENT
AND IT'S GIVEN TO OBEY EAST
MEMBER. WHO EXEMPLIFIES SELF
SACRIFICE VISION ACCOMPLISHMENTS
ALL THROUGHOUT?
THEIR LEADERSHIP AND
INVOLVEMENT IN THE COMMUNITIES
AND HE REALLY SHAPED THE REAL
ESTATE PROFESSION IN THE EAST
BAY.
HE FOUNDED THE HAS CENTER
MORTGAGE GROUP NEARLY THIRTY
YEARS AGO AND ALSO SERVED ON THE
BOARD OF DIRECTORS FOR THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS. IN HIS PERSONAL LIFE
MIKE WAS VERY WELL LOVED BY HIS
WIFE MARY ROBERTSON AND HIS
STEPSON RYAN BURGESS.
OUR COMMUNITY IS GOING TO REALLY
MISS MIKE.
REMEMBER HIM FOR HIS NOT ONLY
CONTINUED INCREDIBLE ATHLETICISM
BUT HIS LEADERSHIP IN OUR
COMMUNITY AND I OFFER MY DEEPEST
CONDOLENCES TO MIKE'S FRIENDS
AND FAMILY AND MEMBERS I ASKED
WE ADJOURN IN HIS MEMORY TODAY
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SOME REMEMBER COOPER
YOUR RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS
THIS MORNING I'M ADJOURNING IN
THE MEMORY OF MY CONSTITUENTS.
JOE REALLY.
JOE WAS BORN IN THE SUBIC NAVAL
BASE IN THE ZONE PHILIPPINES ON
NOVEMBER TWENTY FIFTH NINETEEN
SIXTY FOUR.
MISTER ROWAN SERVED OUR COUNTRY
UNITED STATES MARINE CORPS
NECTARS ARBIL MILITARY SERVICE
HE ATTENDED. HILLS ENGINEERING
COLLEGE INCENTIVE CLARA.
IN NINETEEN NINETY FOUR JILL
BEGIN WORKING WITH UNITED STATES
POSTAL SERVICE
IT CULMINATED IN A TWENTY FOUR
YEAR. CAREER AS A MAIL CARRIER.
ON MONDAY FEBRUARY TWELFTH IF
THE AGE OF FIFTY THREE MISTER
REAL AND PASSED AWAY DUE TO
COMPLICATIONS
FROM INFLUENZA.
JOE LOVE THE OUTDOORS.
REMOTE CONTROL CARS MOTORIZED
BIKES AND SCOOTERS NEED TO
QATAR'S GRANDFATHER WITH A GREEN
THUMB.
IS SURVIVED BY HIS WIFE ETHEL.
THE CHILDREN BREANNA NATHAN AND
HIS MOTHER. JOSIE.
MY HOPE FOR PRAYERS BROUGHT TO
MR GRIEVANCE FAMILY AND FRIENDS.
WILL BE DEEPLY MISSED.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
ADJOURN IN HIS MEMORY.
THANK YOU.
MEMBERS PLEASE BRING THE NAMES
TO THE TEST REPRINTED IN THE
JOURNAL ALL ACROSS TWO ADJOINING
MEMORY WILL BE DEEMED READ AND
PRINTED IN THE JOURNAL.
ALL OTHER ITEMS REMAINING WILL
BE PASS AND RETAIN ALL MOTIONS
HUBBY CONTINUED SEEING IT HERE
THERE NO SINGING HEARING NO
FURTHER BUSINESS I'M READY TO
ENTERTAIN A MOTION TO ADJOURN.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BAKER MOVE TO
MISTER COOPER SECONDS OF THIS
HOUSE STANDS ADJOURNED UNTIL
MONDAY FEBRUARY TWENTY SIXTH AT
ONE PM